think so at this point from what
everybody is saying I'm hearing it from
all sides
I feel like in today's society the
safest and probably healthiest thing for
you to do is to have an agreement
between a man and a woman who agree on
the values that they want to put on
their child to grow feel to be whatever
human they want that child to be and
leave it as that possession love
marriage all of these things are
fantasies that we're listening in
today's age don't have as much standing
what does have standing is a respectful
relationship with somebody and that
doesn't mean you have to live together I
would love listen I swear to God I would
love to to be able to have a man that
will give me my children but he does not
have to have me and we can still
cooperate and we can still raise the
children together but you have your own
house I have my own house Daddy has his
own space he likes his house and Daddy's
house is your house I have my own space
at my house and Mommy's house is also
your house and Daddy can come to my
house Mommy can go to his house because
we're good friends we get on really well
we have a lot for each other we want it
like that because I don't think I can I
don't want I don't think I would be
happy for the rest of my life and I
would be able to actually give the kind
of love and the kind of good energy and
positivity to my child when I have
somebody else attached to me that
because in so many ways because we're
different people just in general they
will drag my energy down sometimes and I
don't think that you're expecting your
happiness before the kids
if it goes back to like what I've been
saying you're clearly Twisted I'm going
I'm teaching listen I'm going the other
way my happiness and this is thing I
know this very well because I know when
my mom came when we came to England I
remember my mom had to work and all
these things my mom's happiness was
something that was very important to us
seeing her struggle seeing her suffering
that way seeing it to go through all of
these things was really impactful on us
are you're not gonna control up your
emotions no of course I can be in
control of my emotions but if I'm happy
okay so then can you can you put on a
happy front for your kids uh the thing
is you can put in a happy front for your
kids but this is the thing about kids
that most people tend to forget children
are not stupid do you understand exactly
you can always catch well you can always
know when things are not okay with mommy
or daddy things change your behavior
will change no matter how much you try
to pretend and fake it it will always be
visible and that's why I would say
nowadays save yourself and actually be
with somebody not be with them forever
but have a good contract a good
relationship with them I think that's
the future of dating as long I don't
think it's going to be the two house
thing it Britain's too high in London
but but I do think that like long term
it's going to be like long-term
relationships outside of marriage and if
people do get married they'll date for
longer first where it seems to be going
I think that's what's going to be
because these days the way that we're
talking about women at this men and that
then nobody's trusting anybody to
actually have that commitment for Life
the only way you can have a commitment
for life is if you take away the
possession and the me and you together
and you make it about the child so it
doesn't even matter if you're together
or not because what you love the most is
that kid and you want that kid to grow
happy so you get on and it's reflected
in all aspects of life you don't have a
job for life anymore you have a few jobs
and whichever job gives you the most
money you stick with like it's not
I don't think I think the family is just
what's it just shows what's happening in
society it's just a reflection I beg to
differ reason being is that
um
I think once you've once you have a
child
it's not it's no longer about you it's
really about the children and if it just
means that you just take it as a job
and in front of the children because
what children are like sponges right and
whatever you're referring to is whatever
your mum exposed to you or whatever your
father exposed to you and this if if
you're once you have children in my
opinion you have to do the best that you
can do to give them the best possible
upbringing
in some cases at your expense because
as statistics suggests
that extra effort prevents a child from
entering a prison system and prevents a
child from going through certain
development stages that they don't need
to go for and these kind of things so I
just think like once you have a child in
a picture of marriage or not the charge
should be the priority irrespective of
where you stand you the child comes
first before you in my opinion so that's
that's pretty much what I was saying
earlier like if if you're together and
you've got a kid and the relationship's
not working out then just co-inhabit you
can live together and be roommates and
live in the same house as long as the
kids see the the unit you you eat
together at a dinner table all that kind
of stuff
no but no no but if Arrangement like you
both agreed to like it's not
your thing no but listen it's not
working between us yeah
somewhere else have a separate room just
just let us out just let the children
exactly if it's not working out we can
come to an arrangement
exactly
we're not saying that's the ideal
situation but I'm just I'm putting like
if I was in that situation and I think
Hmm I know it's better for my kids if
the mom and the dad are in the home and
if for a couple years I just have to be
in separate bedrooms and figure out how
to deal with this guy I don't like like
I'm gonna do it I chose to make a kid
with him if I didn't want to do that I
shouldn't have chosen to make a kid with
him but Corey hubby until the kids are
at least of age to kind of understand
when you start splitting up the home
when the kids are like under 10 confuses
them they start thinking it's their
fault the worst thing for children is to
not have a mom and a dad in a house I
agree with what um I forgot your name
what you're saying Pierre and what
Paul's saying it's the worst thing and I
feel like if you didn't want to have
kids of that person then you should have
been more careful but you need to think
about the children because their
childhood really shapes the way they are
especially really like not having a dad
and I feel like you just need to firm
some things and happiness
it comes and goes can I ask you a
question would you rather your mom and
dad were together but you watch your dad
treat your mom like like I would rather
my mum and dad be together but like some
people have suggested different ways of
going about things rather than
like someone running away like but with
that with the ideology of like
cohabitation and like just living
together and being unhappy and like
sleeping in separate beds and like just
putting on a front for the whole family
like he said the ideology of like kids
like being like a sponge they absorb
like what's going on around them they
are they're not stupid they are seeing
what's happening your parents are
sleeping in separate beds that literally
as they grow up that like tells them
like oh that like like stops them from
being intimate with Partners later in
life because they don't see this
intimacy between their parents the two
people that like learning from and
living with and staff and they're seeing
like this unhappiness like whether it's
a front or not like they are like seeing
that your mom and your dad like aren't
happy together so how is this like how
is that better for the kids what's
what's the better better alternative
wait wait wait they're in separate
they're in separate houses and then they
get to meet their girlfriends and
boyfriends over the years so I don't
think you should meet their other
partners but I think you should be able
to see your parents happy I think you
should see your parents respecting their
own boundaries and it teaches
individualism rather than dependency
marriage and family isn't about
individualism and that's my whole point
it's a me me culture but you said
yourself you said that this is a
post-marriage society so why should we
be trying to backtrack on society like
this is the way society's growing like
we just have to accept and move on yeah
I think yeah I think it's regardless of
whether it's for the better of society
it's better for the individual like oh
you should really care about is your
self-worth and your self happiness I
think marriage as an institution is dead
I still think there will be families but
I I think
um yeah as legally as an institution I
think it's dead but how would you feel
if you saw your your daughter or your
son in a relationship they weren't happy
in you wouldn't save them because I mean
I would I would rather see if I if I had
a daughter let's say was that was with a
guy I didn't like yeah I probably would
have warned her not to have a kid with
him I'd like to say I probably would
have to we're women right we do it
anyway so so she has a kid with him I
warned you not to do it now you made
your bed like I I would just say lion it
you lie in it until he's 18. especially
especially in life will you lose outside
of abuse sorry go ahead you lose so much
value for yourself though when you're
with someone that you know isn't good
for you or you know it isn't I don't
know what like you lose value for
yourself like I don't really go with
them but I'm like a punishment yeah yeah
and I'm saying it's a it's a you're it's
a punishment you chose poorly but I'm a
big right but I'm saying I'm saying be
accountable for what you chose you
picked it you made that you made that
choice in half the weight wait wait and
half the
time women pick men they know would not
be good Fathers
I
kind of get where you're coming from
like respect the institution family
first I always get that but like so what
if and I suppose this also goes to the
cohabiting thing because I get it like
you're still trying to make it work even
though you're not sleeping together like
you're there's a separation but there's
this idea that we're still here you can
be friends for the kids yeah so but what
happens if you can see that and I'm not
trying to trap you up I'm genuinely
asking like if you can see this
situation you together even cohabiting
cohabitating you get along so poorly
even when trying that you can see it's
making the children unhappy at that
point then I would say yeah you got to
separate but at least by at least try at
least I give will a delicious
those kids are happy bro
I've seen it I've seen it I've seen
family members literally live together
for like five years and they weren't
together together but they just lived in
the same house and they slept in
separate rooms and the aisle four is
even as a child like why why are they
still together but it showed like after
a while for me personally it just showed
strength yeah and then
after the the situation in that period
where they whatever was going on between
them I think it lasted like five years
maybe even longer but they ended up
coming back together afterwards and for
me it's actually witnessing that it was
a beautiful as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible